today is an important victory for me and
for the UN Human Rights system but it by
no means erases seven years of detention
without charge in prison under house
arrest and almost five years here in
this embassy without sunlight seven
years without charge why my children
grew up without me that is not something
that I can forgive it is not something
that I can forget
the inevitable inquiry into what has
occurred in this moment of terrible
injustice it's something that I hope
will be more than just about me and this
situation because the reality is
detention and extradition without charge
has become a feature of the European
Union a feature which has been exploited
yes in my case for political reasons but
in other cases has subjected many people
to terrible injustice in Sweden
indefinite detention is a policy there
is no time limit that someone can be
detained without charge that is not how
we expect a civilized States to behave
similarly extradition without charge is
not something that we expect from the
rule of law in the United Kingdom it's a
measure that was introduced as part of
the European Union system to turn the
European Union into a Federation in 2014
in response to my situation and other
abuses the UK government changed the law
to prevent further extradition without
charge from the UK but it is still a
problem in the rest of the European
Union
I would like to thank in this situation
the United Nations particularly its
human rights system which is the last
resort that we all have when we are
bound up in our legal circumstances with
the particular politics of a country or
the geopolitics that exists between
different states I would also like to
thank Ecuador its people and its Asylum
system who have stood by my Asylum
despite very intense pressure including
pressure to use the European Union's
trade system to penalize Ecuadorian
exporters and the terrible violation I'd
also like to thank my legal team who
worked very hard and for no money and
all the other people that have stood by
me in this process but let us understand
while today was an important victory and
in important vindication the road is far
from over the war the proper war is just
commencing the UK has said it will
arrest me regardless now the United
States
CIA director Pompeo and the US Attorney
General have said that I and other
WikiLeaks staff have no rights
we have no First Amendment rights and
that my arrest and the arrest of our
other staff is a priority that's not
acceptable
WikiLeaks will continue its publications
today in fact we published a new
important
material from the Central Intelligence
Agency CIA vault seven Athena a system
to penetrate and spy on the in a
statistical way anyone that the CIA
happens to be interested in such
measures are conducted without warrant
and the threats towards me my staff and
WikiLeaks as a publisher will not be
tolerated and have not been tolerated
our publications are proceeding at speed
and that's speed in relation to the CIA
is accelerating but finally finally in
relation to the asylum rights that we
all have we do all have them
the United Kingdom the European Union is
a party to the 1951 Convention on
refugees it states that it adheres for
the right for all people to seek asylum
to receive asylum and to enjoy asylum I
have that right you know political case
we all have that right so the claim by
the United Kingdom that it has a right
to arrest me for seeking asylum in a
case where there have been no charges
which is now being dismissed is simply
untenable
by staff my legal staff have contacted
the United Kingdom authorities and we
hope to engage in a dialogue about what
is the best way forward to some extent
the United Kingdom has been
exploited by the process that he entered
into with the European Union where it
agreed to extradite people without
charge or any consideration as as to the
facts that is to an extent of force
position that United Kingdom has been a
force position that United Kingdom has
been put into and the first part of that
is over the UK refuses to confirm or
deny at this stage where the US
extradition warrant is already in the UK
territory that's the dialogue that we
want to happen similarly with the United
States while there have been extremely
threatening remarks made I'm always
happy to engage in a dialogue with the
Department of Justice about what has
occurred finally we have had another
very important victory this week even
more important and more conclusive than
the one we have achieved today and that
is the release of chelsea manning from
prison after seven years detained in the
military prison through an extensive
fight we and others managed to have him
released 28 years early from his
sentence alleged wikileaks sauce chelsea
manning there's some very important
victories but the legal conflict with
the United States and the United Kingdom
at a formal level continues and I and
WikiLeaks as a publisher
encourage you to continue to support us
in that fight for us of course for our
ledge sources but also because
precedents are being set the precedent
about whether people have the right to
seek asylum and the precedent about
whether we have the right to publish
information all of us how can it be that
a journalist and publisher operating
from Europe it can be extradited to the
United States we don't operate in the
United States we don't publish from the
United States so that's it that's a
threat to all journalists around the
world wherever they operate that if they
expose serious abuses occurring in the
national security domain there's a
threat to extradite them publish and to
extradite them or indict the
organization or their staff okay that's
it
thanks guys